at the end it could have been prevented
when they find out about the a couple of
months ago cardi B has another PSA I got
a whole lot to talk about
the rapper jumped on Instagram sporting
a surgical mask to admit she's confused
about the corona virus testing if a
celebrity is saying hey listen I don't
have no symptoms I'm feeling good I feel
healthy I don't feel like nothing but I
went and got tested and I'm positive for
the corner virus that caused confusion
cardi called out celebrities who have
the luxury of paying to get themselves
tested while others can't even afford
health care people who work regular jobs
people that get regular paychecks the
middle class the you know poor whatever
the crowd they're not getting they're
not getting treated like at like like
like the height celebrities and
everything they're not getting the next
day the 27 year old said she knew
someone under 30 who had symptoms but
couldn't get tested unless they were
sick for eight days she also noted that
people in their 40s to 60s who have
symptoms can get tested but are still
being sent home to wait for their
results not everybody has the luxury to
go into the bedroom and to go in a big
ass house and just stay away from people
people live in small as apartments a lot
of people live in small an apartment
with multiple people so that if you
sending me home and I have the corona
virus I'm most likely gonna get a tool
now my spouse my kids anybody that's
around me before wrapping up her lengthy
video cardi B goes off on the government
on a virus treatment for testing for all
this I feel like the government should
take that [ __ ] put projects for the game
and that charge people for if this isn't
the first time the rapper has called out
the higher-ups government about I've
done this down it but from
want China not dripping in gold while
rocking a chained
stress cardi had no chill guy on front a
bitch's kid I'm a little skating I'm
saying like hook that me panicking we
feel you go around the very room also
relatable this yep our girl is losing it
during self-isolation by going headfirst
through a Jenga tower we're being real
we're being in the moment being in the
moment
[Music]